In this video we will examine the liquid-mosaic model
of the cell membranes.
Why is it called a liquid-mosaic model?
To be clear
what we see,
if this is a cell here,
this is her membrane,
it isolates the inside of the cell
from the outside environment.
Here we see a transverse cut of the membrane.
Below is the inside of the cage.
If we compare the two charts,
it's the inside of the cell, and that's the outside environment.
When we look closer,
this little part here
is actually made up of a double phospholipid layer.
I call double phospholipid layer,
but what is phospholipid?
That's a good question.
When you understand what phospholipids are,
it will be clearer why they form
double layers like this and why they are at the root
of so many membranes in biological systems.
This is a phospholipid,
I will record it,
this is a phospholipid.
And as the name suggests, it is made up of a lipid and a phosphate group.
We have a whole video about lipids,
as a whole, the word lipid
means something that does not easily dissolve in water.
This is true of this phospholipid.
It has hydrocarbon tails,
which come from fatty acids.
These hydrocarbon tails
have no charge or polarity.
We know the water molecule is polar,
therefore, can form hydrogen bonds
and is attracted by other water molecules.
But these tails are not polar,
they are not attracted to water and
water is not attracted to them.
These tails are hydrophobic.
We have hydrophobic tails,
they are
lipid part of the phospholipids.
Then we have the phosphate head
right here.
As you can see, she has a charge.
Charged molecules feel good in polar solvents like water.
They will dissolve easily, therefore this part
will be hydrophilic.
In fact, molecules that have a hydrophilic part
and a hydrophobic portion
have a special name.
They are called amphipathic, sometimes it is difficult to pronounce this word.
Phospholipids are amphipathic,
which means they have a hydrophilic end,
which is attracted to the water,
and a hydrophobic end which is not.
I hope this starts to clarify why phospholipids
are organized in this way.
You can imagine,
that hydrophilic heads will want to be there,
where water is. It will either
outside or inside the cage.
Hydrophobic tails
will repel the water
or going away from the water.
So they will stand against each other
inside the membrane.
But the best of such a structure,
made of this amphipathic molecule is that
allows creation
of these double phospholipid layers.
This is remarkable.
If we go back,
even before the formation of cellular forms of life,
phospholipids could form
these spheres surrounded by a double phospholipid layer.
I will draw them cut crosswise,
so that you can imagine them.
I hope I will make a nice picture.
I think to paint
the whole thing
and you will most likely get it.
This will be one layer
of phosphate heads pointing outwards.
This is the inner layer,
I draw a cross cut.
Then we have hydrophobic tails.
I will make them in another color.
Here are the hydrophobic tails. I think you understand.
We have hydrophobic tails on both sides.
Therefore, a structure can be spontaneously formed,
which begins to resemble
of the protocell.
Obviously, in order to have a real life,
we need some kind of information to be passed on to the generations,
as well as some kind of metabolism.
Then the cell will be alive in all life definitions.
You can imagine how this basic structure of the cell membrane
is also formed prior to the appearance of live cells
with the help of the amphipathic properties of molecules such as phospholipids.
All right.
We can form a double phospholipid layer,
and all these other things I've painted here?
These are proteins. This here is an example of protein,
this here is protein,
this is white, it's white.
He drew a few ellipses,
to denote the different types of proteins.
But it is important to understand that
in cells, there is a wide variety of membrane proteins.
The membrane is a lot
complex structure.
She is not
homogeneous double phospholipid layer,
there are a lot of things in it.
If we look at this cut,
we will see them.
We see them on this chart.
We can say that there is a mosaic of things in the phospholipid double layer.
Mosaic is a picture made by
different components, colored in different colors.
As you can see, here we have all the components,
different types of proteins.
We have proteins like the ones that pass through the membrane.
These are transmembrane proteins,
this is a special class of integral proteins.
We have integrated proteins like this,
which are in contact with one part of the double layer,
until they cross it all.
We also have glycolipids.
This is a glycolipid here.
Glycolipids are remarkable.
They nest in the membrane,
because they have a lipid end,
which is hydrophobic.
He'll get along well with everyone
remaining hydrophobic items in the membrane.
But their other end is a chain of sugars,
this end will be hydrophilic
and will point to the external environment.
These sugar chains
are very important for intercellular recognition.
Your immune system uses them to distinguish
cells
of your body -
those with whom he should not enter into confession,
those who have to defend
from the cells that are foreign to the body,
those who can attack.
When people talk about blood groups,
they talk about
specific glycolipids we have on our cells.
This does not exhaust the subject
for glycolipids and their role
in intercellular recognition
or designation.
Remarkably, these chains of sugars
can participate in so complex and useful
cell behavior.
But we do not just want sugar chains of lipids,
we also want sugar chains of proteins.
Here we have a glycoprotein.
As you can see, all these things are arranged
in a mosaic. Actually, we have not finished yet.
In the membrane we have cholesterol.
Cholesterol is a lipid, so he will stay
in the hydrophobic portion of the membrane.
It contributes to the fluidity of the membrane,
helps her not to be too fluid or too stiff.
It's cholesterol.
So far we have seen the parts of the mosaic in the membrane,
and the liquid part?
I just mentioned the role of cholesterol
in maintaining the right level of fluidity.
The good thing about this structure is that it is not rigid.
If these things get collapsed
or if something goes away,
the phospholipids will be rearranged spontaneously
and will fill the gap.
You can imagine that all these things are floating around,
that this membrane has the consistency
of vegetable oil or of salad dressing.
It has no elastic, rubber texture
like a balloon.
It's actually liquid. These things can move around,
but although it is liquid,
can divide the two environments.
The internal environment of the cell
from the outside environment.
That is why we call the liquid-mosaic membrane model.